un experto de control de calidad en una
fábrica embotelladora de bebidas tomo
una muestra aleatoria de botellas de un
lote y midió la cantidad de líquido en
cada botella de la muestra las
cantidades en la muestra tuvieron una
media de 503 mililitros y una desviación
estándar de 5 mililitros quiere probar
si esto es evidencia suficiente de que
la cantidad media en las botellas de
este lote es diferente al valor objetivo
de 500 mililitros se amo la cantidad
media de líquido en cada botella de lote
escribe un conjunto apropiado de
hipótesis para la prueba de
significancia del experto en control de
calidad pausa el vídeo y ver si puedes
resolverlo vamos a ver primero
necesitamos tener dos hipótesis la
hipótesis nula y la hipótesis
alternativa la hipótesis nula es una
hipótesis sobre el parámetro de la
población que nos interesa y va a
suponer un tipo de statu quo
entonces el parámetro que nos interesa
es la cantidad media de líquido en las
botellas del lote eso seríamos y cuál
sería la suposición del valor de esta
tenemos alguna información bueno sabemos
que es 500 mililitros ese es el valor
objetivo por lo tanto es razonable decir
que la hipótesis nula está haciendo lo
que se supone que debe hacer es decir
que la media real del lote es lo que se
necesita para que sea el objetivo que es
de 500 mililitros muchos de ustedes tal
vez pensar oye espera no nos dijeron que
las cantidades en la muestra tuvieron
una media de 503 mililitros
porque aquí no son 503 mililitros
bueno recuerden que nuestra hipótesis
tiene que ver con el parámetro de la
población estos 500 3 mililitros son la
muestra estadística
esta es la media muestral que está
tratando de estimar esta cosa de aquí
entonces cuando realizamos nuestra
prueba de significancia vamos a
incorporar estos 503 mililitros y vamos
a pensar en cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener una muestra estadística que se
encuentre así de lejos o aún más de la
media supuesta esto considerando que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera y si resulta
que esa probabilidad se encuentra por
debajo del umbral de nuestro nivel de
significancia simplemente rechazamos la
hipótesis nula y sugerimos la hipótesis
alternativa pero si solamente tratamos
de generar o mejor dicho escribir un
conjunto de hipótesis esta es nuestra
hipótesis nula y nuestra hipótesis
alternativa es que la verdadera media
para elote es diferente a 500 mililitros
hemos terminado nos vemos en otro vídeo